now that you've learned a thing about a
thing or two about significant figures i
want to use this video to make sure that
you don't overdo it in situations where
it might be disastrous and to give you
an example there let's say that i were
to tell you that someone or something i
don't know let's say something is
112 centimeters
let me write this way 112. actually
let's make it interesting 112.2
centimeters
long some object
long so there's some object you know
it's
112.2 centimeters long you're able to
measure to the nearest tenth of a
centimeter of how long it is and then
someone were to ask you well how long
would five of these objects be so let me
write that down how long
how long would
five of these objects end to end how
long would that be so you have one
object you put another object three
objects four objects five objects how
long would this be and so before we even
talked about significant figures you
would just say well it's 112.2 times
five so let's multiply that out 112.2
times five
five times two is ten
carry or i guess you could say regroup
the one two times five is ten plus one
is eleven
one times five is five plus one is six
one times five is five and we have one
number behind the decimal so we get
561.0
and so there's something interesting
here so let me rewrite it we have 112.2
times five and we get 500
561.0 and this was in centimeters and
then this is going to be in centimeters
as well
and you look at the significant and now
all of a sudden let's care about the
significant figures so in this right
over here in this measurement you have
one two three four significant figures
four significant figures
but there might be a temptation for you
to say wait i'm multiplying that by
something that only has one significant
figure five is only one significant
figure so shouldn't my answer only have
one significant figure
and that would be completely wrong that
would be a disaster and the reason why
is that you shouldn't count the five
when you're calculating significant
figures because this was not a
measurement this is a pure number this
is you could have written
5.0000 we're taking exactly five of
these objects and putting them next to
each other this isn't some approximation
some measurement so this doesn't this
this this is of infinite precision so
this doesn't affect the significant
figure calculation it is a pure number
you're seeing exactly five so in this
situation you once again just look at
the measurements and there's only one
measurement here has four significant
figures so our product in this case
should have four significant figures so
our product actually the way we wrote it
right here actually does have four
significant figures
so this would be a completely this would
be a completely legitimate thing to
write down and that's because this has
infinite precision it is a pure pure
number